hello grammarians today we are going to
talk skillfully and patiently about
adverbs and what it is that adverbs do
and in order to do that I think it might
be useful to talk about what adjectives
do first
so adjectives can modify stuff and I
should have been clearer in the last
video and said that the stuff they
modify is nouns but I didn't want to
introduce too many rules and strictures
what adjectives modify is nouns and only
nouns adverbs modify everything else so
adverbs modify everything that's not a
noun and the way we usually see this
applied is with verbs and it's right
there in the name to add verbs and this
comes from the Latin meaning on or two
verbs action words adverbs are words
that you slap on to verbs basically what
I imagined when I think of adverbs is I
kind of see like a like a sticker here's
this sticker we've got we can say slowly
so we can take we can take this thing
and turn it into a sticker Boop move it
around
do we like so we can write a sentence
like Grayson ran Boop slowly you know
and and slowly here refers back to ran
it's how he ran not really describing
Grayson it's it's modifying or
describing the action of running Perle
arranged the furniture slowly Boop
little sticker we just put on there but
a word is also considered an adverb if
it modifies and
adjectives so let's say adverbs modify
verbs and adjectives so we could say
something like vanessa was very hungry
right because hungry is an adjective and
very is doing this thing where it's
modifying hungry it's not Vanessa wasn't
very you can't be very varies not an
adjective but it is a modifier and the
word that it's modifying is hungry how
hungry was Vanessa Vanessa was very
hungry Vanessa could also be slightly
hungry and this leads me to one of the
most important things about adverbs
which is that generally they tend to
have ly on them so generally the way to
make an adverb is to just take an
adjective and add ly to it so you take
the word slow ya del Y you get the
adverb slowly you take the word nice ya
del Y you get the adverb nicely you take
the adjective cheerful and now why you
get the adverb cheerfully so adverbs
modify everything that isn't a noun and
that means that they modify verbs and
adjectives the way you make an adverb
most of the time is by just taking an
adjective and tacking on ly to the end
of it it's like a sticker that you put
on top of a verb or an adjective
that's what adverbs are and that's what
they do and what you can do is learn
anything
damn it out